responde las siguientes preguntas sobre
la solubilidad del hidróxido de calcio
aquí nos dan su producto de solubilidad
escribe la ecuación química balanceada
para la disolución del hidróxido de
calcio sólido en agua pura entonces
vamos a empezar con el hidróxido de
calcio que se encuentra en estado sólido
y cuando es disuelto está en equilibrio
con los iones de calcio que tienen una
carga 2 positiva y escribimos que están
en solución acuosa porque acuérdense que
lo estamos disolviendo en agua más los
iones hidróxido también disueltos en
agua
y por cada calcio tenemos 2 hidróxidos
ahí está esta es nuestra ecuación
química balanceada un calcio un calcio 2
hidróxidos 2 hidróxidos ok vamos con la
siguiente parte calcula la solubilidad
molar de el hidróxido de calcio ahora en
una solución que contiene una
concentración de otra sal que es nitrato
de calcio 0.1 molar y tal vez ya sepan
que esta es una sal muy soluble porque
es una sal de nitrato y eso la hace muy
muy soluble muy soluble y como
resolvemos esto como calculamos la
solubilidad molar del hidróxido de
calcio que tanto calcio se puede
disolver si ya tenemos calcio disuelto
en la solución bueno sin importar la
concentración de calcio que se disuelva
se disolverá el doble de concentración
de hidróxido y tal vez ya sepan que esto
tiene que ver con el producto de
solubilidad
y el producto de solubilidad es igual a
la concentración bueno en realidad es
igual al producto de las concentraciones
de las dos cosas que estamos disolviendo
entonces es igual a la concentración de
los iones de calcio por la concentración
de iones hidróxido y como tenemos dos
moles de hidróxido por cada molde de
calcio entonces esto va elevado al
cuadrado ahí está
ahora algunos de ustedes tal vez me
digan oye esto se parece mucho a la
constante de equilibrio bueno un poco
pero si estuviéramos trabajando con la
constante de equilibrio esto tendría que
estar dividido entre la concentración de
los reactivos pero para la concentración
del reactivo en este caso el reactivo se
encuentra en estado sólido vamos a
visualizar lo que está pasando
imagínense que aquí tenemos un bloque de
hidróxido de calcio sólido que está
sumergido en el agua y hemos saturado la
solución de tantos iones de calcio como
podamos entonces cada vez que disolvemos
hidróxido de calcio se forma la misma
cantidad y si usáramos la constante de
equilibrio tendríamos que dividir esto
entre la concentración del hidróxido de
calcio sólido y no estamos acostumbrados
a usar concentraciones de sólidos en
términos de molar idad pero finalmente
eso será constante porque si se disuelve
algo de hidróxido de calcio el volumen
del bloque
disminuye y si se forma algo el volumen
aumenta así que la concentración
permanece constante y bueno lo que se
acostumbra es multiplicar ambos lados
por esa concentración y así es como se
obtiene el producto de solubilidad y
como usamos esto bueno ya tenemos lo
escribir ya teníamos algunos iones de
calcio disueltos
ya tenemos una concentración 0.10 molar
de iones de calcio disueltos bueno lo
dejaré así y vamos a agregar agregamos
vamos a decir x molar x molar iones de
calcio al disolver
al disolver el hidróxido de calcio y
esto significa que tenemos una
concentración 2x molar 2x molar de
hidróxido porque recuerden sin importar
la concentración de iones de calcio que
tengamos tendremos el doble de
concentración de hidróxido porque por
cada molécula de calcio tenemos 2
moléculas de hidróxido ok y como usamos
esto junto con el producto de
solubilidad bueno ya tenemos esto de
aquí ya sabemos que tenemos 0.10 y le
vamos a agregar
quizá esto que escribí sea un poco
confuso mejor borraré los corchetes para
que se entienda mejor porque esto ya nos
está diciendo que es una concentración
ok entonces esta es la concentración de
iones de calcio los que ya teníamos más
los que agregamos y después la
concentración de hidróxido es 2x
recuerden por cada calcio tenemos el
doble de hidróxido y claro esto al
cuadrado esto es igual al producto de
solubilidad que ya nos lo habían dado
nos dijeron que es igual a 1.3 por 10 a
la menos 6 entonces 1.3 por 10 a la
menos 6 ahora si tratamos de resolver
esto así será un poco complicado porque
terminaremos con 4x cuadrada por esto
que nos dará el siguiente término al
cuadrado y luego tendremos otro término
aquí no será muy fácil de resolver pero
una forma de simplificarlo es suponer
que especialmente como esta sal de
nitrato es muy soluble incluso más
soluble que la sal de hidróxido podemos
suponer que ésta
parte es aproximadamente igual a 0.1 ya
que x x es mucho menor que cero punto 10
qué 0.10 esa es la suposición que
podemos hacer y tenemos que saber que
bueno primero que esto será difícil de
resolver si lo dejamos así pero también
como estamos agregando algo que es menos
soluble a algo que está muy cerca de la
saturación está es una concentración muy
alta y más tarde podemos regresar a esta
parte para verificar si al hacer esta
suposición y conociendo el valor de x
obtenemos algo muy parecido al valor del
producto de solubilidad entonces si
hacemos esta suposición nos queda que
1.3 por 10 a la menos 6 es igual a 0.10
por 4x cuadrada y entonces podemos decir
que x cuadrada es igual a 1.3 por 10 a
la menos 6 / 0.10 por 4 o incluso
podemos decir / 0.40 y entonces nos
queda que x es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de esto entonces x es igual a usemos la
calculadora tenemos 1.3 x 10 a la menos
6 entre 0.4 que es igual a eso y la raíz
cuadrada de eso es igual a vamos a ver
cuantas cifras significativas queremos
bueno aquí hemos estado trabajando con
dos entonces esto es igual a 0.00 18
esto es aproximadamente igual a 0.00 18
déjenme verificar 000.00 18 molar
esta es nuestra respuesta y si quieren
verificar la pueden sustituir este valor
en esta ecuación y podrán comprobar que
les da un valor muy cercano a 1.3 por 10
a la menos 6 ahora vamos con la última
parte en el recuadro de abajo completa
el diagrama de representación de una
partícula que incluya cuatro moléculas
de agua con su orientación adecuada
alrededor de lyon de calcio bueno
sabemos que las moléculas de agua son
polares este es el oxígeno
este es un hidrógeno y este también es
un hidrógeno y también tenemos un par de
electrones libres por aquí así que
tenemos una carga parcial negativa y por
acá tenemos cargas parciales positivas
en los hidrógenos entonces necesitamos
orientar las moléculas de agua de tal
forma que la parte del oxígeno esté
hacia el calcio que es positivo porque
la carga parcial negativa es atraída a
la carga positiva entonces ya tenemos
una aquí tenemos dos ésta es la 3 y esta
es la 4 y nos pidieron que sólo
dibujemos 4 y bueno si queremos dejar
todo claro
estos son los oxígenos y estos son los
hidrógenos y los hidrógenos tienen una
carga parcial positiva como esta parte
de la molécula tiene una carga parcial
positiva
el lyon de calcio los repele y como el
otro lado tiene los pares de electrones
libres tiene una carga parcial negativa
así que es atraída a la carga positiva
ahí está